zach obviously wanted to go in a
different direction than than had been
released in the previous movie um
the nice thing for us was that there the
design was already there
the steppenwolf design from the
zagsteiner version is in the
post-credit scene of batman vs superman
so that design was already there so it
wasn't
we didn't necessarily have to come up
with something there was already
zach already had a vision in his head
about what that should be
so really it was just it was just visual
or was just
implementing it and and coming up with
some cool uh
shading for his kind of iridescent steel
but the overall design was already done
it wasn't that we just had like the old
version was like version 12 and then we
just started version 13 so we did have a
new asset
so it was in that sense it was all for
scratch from scratch
and the nice everything on top of that
really
once we had the the model and the shader
would would be
that it's also i think in the new uh in
the new film
the new version of the film uh a
different character
and there's a lot more story development
it would have been uh
telling that story more less with how he
looks and more about how he
how he moves and acts and emotes and the
performance that he gives from through
animation and
facial capture yeah that we definitely
didn't just
slap him on top of the motion that we
had from 2017 um because proportionally
he's
much broader he's got different um
fingers he's got this funny thumb that's
halfway up his arm as well so
um if it was gesturing with his hands in
the previous film when we were replacing
that shot we had to take all that into
account
we probably sometimes we had to even
reframe because it's just a different
shape right um so also the
the design when you look at it visually
you're just like wow he's just way more
badass and
he's got a lot more stature and presence
and so
we took that into account um when it was
replacing an existing shot we just
edited it a little bit
um just with the animators doing that
but going into
new shots um and fresh performance we
just took that into account and how
our stunt performers um worked with with
that new asset on the mocap stage so we
definitely
you know we looked at how he carried
himself in a in a slightly
different way as well so yeah that
design certainly influenced how we
approached
the motion on him for sure also even in
shots where we are just
updating you know the old one with a new
one like it's
particularly in the you know the early
part of the thermoscera attack
when he's got amazon's like clambering
all over him and and he's interacting
directly with
um the amazonians it's like that him
being a completely different shape is a
bit of a nightmare because suddenly all
the the position of all of the amazons
like that
where they were grabbing his arm when
he's reaching for the mother box their
hand positions don't match anymore so we
have to then move everything around
around it including you know taking
pieces of plate that were there before
you know live action capture and either
like moving it or replacing it with cg
to get all that work so it ends up being
quite fiddly to get that new design
working with old material that was shot
one of the great things about working
with zach is he has a very clear visual
idea about what he's after so that
you know was maintained from 2017 to
2021 in terms of dark side design
obviously we never completely finished
building dark side the first time around
so there's a bunch of work just to get
him up to scratch you know maybe to
polish him off
so that he could shine on screen but in
terms of design it's the same
design as was originally conceived for
the original version the scene
where we get a glimpse of apocalypse we
did that work and it was kind of nice to
have this
vignette of only a few shots but but
having that opportunity to
to with just a couple shots build a
whole world
and try to give the audience a sense of
what the our bad guys
home world could be like and the you
know the fire pits out the window and
his
his massive army and your first glimpse
of
granny goodness and um and assad is is
pretty cool
the idea that that we got from zach
that he had in his head was that you had
you had the same advanced technology
that we can we can build this
you know interdimensional telephone out
of this particles and moving
this molten kind of metal thing that
happens but in
a much more brutalist way right these
guys
just don't care that is polished they
like
you know it's almost that the the
apocalyptians
got it to the point where it worked and
then didn't care about anything that was
wrong with it or like
it's hot metal dripping on the floor
don't care it works
you know they're they're it wanted to be
a reflection of
of as much as the the polished version
was a reflection of the
superman uh kryptonians this wanted to
be a reflection of this brutal
fiery kind of warlike home world that
the the apocalyptians
come from we got as many things models
and textures and ideas and and clips and
and the vendor had
previous shots that weren't that didn't
get all the way to final so we had
kind of a sense of where
thematically they they wanted the
sequence to be and it's it's
your climactic third act battle and as
far as the look goes
you know it wasn't any harder than
anything else because we were
uh basically starting from scratch and
all those all those ideas like
zach was like you know when we got the
turnover from the client they're like no
red sky
that's right out it's like okay i'm fine
that's like you know easy will find a
different sky
and um so so i
it wasn't easy uh because you are kind
of starting from scratch but it
it didn't it didn't make any more
difficult that that
than any other thing that we were
starting from something that was kind of
already there and uh
like half finished the green lantern
scene was largely admitted in 2017
what what you're seeing now was was
intended to be in 2017
to a certain point so it was um from
an animation perspective it was cool to
see it come back and
i think what also dictated um our
approach to the action particularly the
green lantern's death was the fact that
the ratings had changed um
we didn't have to adhere to a certain
rating now that it's going on hbo
um so we were sort of given the
permission to so go a bit more violent
on it so the idea of cutting his hand
off and
really having a brutal sort of death
blow to the chest
um was it was a fun approach so we got
to go
down on the stage redo that all that
performance anders actually came up with
a nice idea of dark side reaching out to
grab the wing before he was hit by the
arrow from
artemis i think it was yeah um so
yeah it was just um kind of
serendipitous how it all came together
with a few ideas thrown around
internally and
and and just bouncing that over to uh dj
and zach and it was was
well well received um and i think
after that initial fight between
darkseid and green lantern
we expanded upon that a little further
with just giving green lantern a bit
more of a moment a hero moment i think
taking off up into the sky and
blasting his ring that leads leads into
that
that beat which was another nice
addition for him so
yeah it was it was a nice addition we we
all enjoyed working on
there's a bit of a inside joke here that
our pipeline changes so fast that
by the end of your show shots that
you've done at the beginning of your
show probably won't work anymore
so that that's the first challenge um
just the pace of technology moves so
fast um
and creatively as well our bar now is
higher than it would have been
even for ourselves in 2017 so it's just
making sure
that this that as we bring all the
material back from the
our initial pass at the 2017 justice
league that we
put the effort in to make sure this
stuff is as best as we can possibly make
it
the one new sequence of zack shot for
this movie it was quite difficult for
them as when it was shot
the u.s was fairly strictly locked down
a lot of coven problems and and even
getting a film crew on a set together
safely was quite difficult but they
managed to do it they managed to
hurt all the cats and and get that
shot and we only had i think a couple
shots
i think was the flash um he couldn't be
on set so
uh whatever actors couldn't actually be
on set to
to shoot the new sequence we added
digitally or were shot in a remote
location on green
for their shots so that they could since
the whole sequence is in this
fantastical world
the entire sequence was shot on green
with some practical cars
and we're adding the the background so
it almost didn't matter
if you were alone in a shot where you
were you could have been in the north
pole you know wherever
the actors were if you could get a
camera on them over green then we could
put them into that world and make sure
everything matches and string it all
together
bvs was so long ago though tech wise for
us it was easier
to take the feeling of that sequence and
and look and
and do it from scratch while making sure
we honor
what it's supposed to look like this
previous shot i was on was
godzilla versus kong and covet hit new
zealand and new zealand went into full
lockdown
just as we were trying to finish that
movie just push towards final and get
everything out
literally from from a friday to a monday
we went from having dailies with people
to
having dailies with everyone at home on
teams
um so then when that so
i feel like it was good because we kind
of figured out
how that worked me personally i figured
out how to run a team and how to run a
show
in in the worst possible moment at the
you know crunch time so then we rolled
into
starting up a new show we were kind of
not pros but it was not
you weren't also fighting the fact that
we were figuring out how to all work
remotely so it was in the sense that it
wasn't the first rodeo at working
remotely so it was it
actually made it a little bit easier
yeah for me personally i was returning
to the film again because i
worked on it in 2017 so it was all
familiar territory
um and and so i could sort of help these
guys out with sort of telling
you know what character went where and
what scene and sort of got these guys
caught up on on all the names and places
and shot numbers and stuff which was fun
but um i think i think the covert
challenge for emotion because it was a
heavy motion capture show
we were finding we're waiting for those
windows where we would come out of
lockdown
for a period of time that would allow us
to do motion capture and if there was
any whiff of a potential lockdown coming
down the schedule we had to really
move on getting to the motion capture
stage and banking as much performance as
possible just in case we went into a
lockdown
um without them the performances that we
needed to put into the shots so um it
was a pretty
stressful schedule um from motion's
point of view dealing with
the backdrop of covert um but thankfully
uh it all worked out and we got what we
needed but it was just
the pressure was on very short schedule
yeah a lot of work yeah um
in a in a short space of time and um the
expectation coming in
oh it's just updating a character in a
few shots
for a new version and you've done half
the work already right so it's going to
be
no it's not easy um yeah there was a
very
aggressive schedule to um to try and get
everything complete
um for their intended release date and
yeah you know as kevin said although we
were able to get stuff up and running or
we already had a workflow going for i'm
dealing with remote
everything like suddenly dealing with
teams that were spread all over the
world rather than
you know it's not not just artists
working at home from
in new zealand but we had artists
working in australia and
india and europe all over the world so
actually you know
marshalling all of those resources
together i think was was a challenge as
well but everyone really stepped up and
managed to pull together to get it done